We still have to do the same things
we had before, so you remember, in,
in tracking,when we were doing
tracking we had this notion of
a dynamics model for and
it was a linear model.
So the idea is that at each time step,
we have some prediction that,
allow, us say, well, if I have some
density about where I think I am,
what's my new density?
And in that particular case,
it had to be linear in order
to make the math work out.
That was, you know,
the underlying part of the, the Kalman.
All right but in general,
we can have a more general
state transition matrix, right?
So the idea is that what is the expected
change from time T to T plus one.
Okay so if I'm at some point or
if I'm guessing that I'm at some point
I can say what's my expected change.
So what's important about this and the
reason I'm going on and on about this is
besides just having a sort of dynamics
model that says how things are likely to
evolve I can also intru, include
a notion of perturbation or control.
All right.
So, the perturbation means if I was
here, maybe I know that I added,
I took two steps to the right.
Now Megan's freaking out again.
All right, I'm back.
All right.
So what I would do is
I would say that okay,
the the expected state
transition is that
I take where I am, I take two steps to
the right, and then I add some noise.
So it's a little bit like, remember when
we talked about that in a linear model
I could actually have a different
linear transition at every time t,
but usually we keep them constant,
here, we're going to have the notion
of an input, and the input is
represented as u, u for input.
Don't ask me.
You, if you, if you want to know why,
ask some control theory professor,
because they always use u as the input,
so it's their desire.
Anyway, so we're going to see a u sub t.
That's the control, or the input,
or the perturbation that got added
to the system at time T and
we assume that we know that, alright?
So what we've done is we've changed
our filtering just a little bit so
that besides just taking observations,
we're going to assume we have
observations plus assume, that we have,
we know what the inputs are, all right?
Lots of words but
I hope that you follow that.